my birthday  so let's get this party started and  there's no better way to do that with  some fabulous drag queens come on out  y'all  [Applause]  drag queens are everywhere right now  literally you hire a plumber someone  shows up to your house if it's not a  dude dressed as a chickie going what's  going on here everybody's a drag queen  now but the masks that those bananas  wackadoodle people in the audience of  the view have nothing better to do than  waste three hours in the middle of the  day to go to that taping  put on masks to be there to then watch a  bunch of men dressed as clownish women  celebrate Whoopi Goldberg and her  Prosecco  Lord give me the strength